you both have a chapter in the book
copywriting clearance that reads
advertising that sells your film can
also kill your film
do tell well that's part of the fair use
chapter and the a lot of filmmakers
think great it's fair use and then they
send the film off to have a trailer made
and some of that material that was fair
use in the film will show up in the
trailer that isn't necessarily true the
the trailer has to be evaluated on its
own to decide whether the material is
fair use as it appears in the trailer
what was it what was the one you worked
on with Mark Ruffalo playing a sex
addict that was called thank you for
sharing okay yeah that was called thank
you for sharing and in that film it was
a little different fair use issue it was
it was a narrative film and Mark Ruffalo
was walking down the street and as he's
walking on the street they capture
purposely images of Victoria's Secret
models images of you know jeans at with
a very sexy woman on it and all these
things and they wanted to use those in
the trailer they appear in the film and
without permission because they captured
them on the street but in the trailer we
had to review that again to make sure
that the use of the trailer was fair use
and we determined it was after many
conversations and getting together and
making sure we were all comfortable with
it and because there was a comment on
those you know it was an explanation of
what the film is about what this guy's
addiction was and how it gets fed by
billboards and media all over the place
it's like oh my god how do you not think
about sex when you're bombarded with
these images and so we determined that
was okay and that was okay to use them
in the trailer so not only does the
actual film all ninety minutes or
whatever and have to pass the fair use
sort of litmus test but then also the
trailer is held up to it he has a
different standard it is a different
standard and also the moat we don't get
a lot of calls or complaints in this
office but most of them come from
trailers or teasers that people put up
on their Kickstarter campaign that have
not been cleared by ads it reaches more
eyeballs and so those trailers and the
teasers etc that are online more people
see them and there's just a higher risk
that someone's going to view it and then
be upset about the use and so often it
comes to our office and they're like oh
we got this webOS letter and then we
find out it from a trailer that we never
even saw we're like oh we wish you would
have shown that to us you know so we
could have at least rendered an opinion
made sure you had insurance in place and
then we're just having such a stronger
bargaining position when that's the case
you